au spi paul nabil a fait pas mal parler
d'elle aujourd'hui j'avais pourquoi je
vais vous le dire
ses fesses aussi elle a annoncé qu'elle
allait se marier avec thomas vergara
regarder mais que maintenant ça fait un
petit moment qu'on est ensemble avec mon
chéri y est et on a vraiment envie de se
marier c'est vrai c'est l'homme de ma
vie en atout
on a tout surmonté ensemble et c'est un
aboutissement que le mari ne serait ce
que par rapport à nous pour se sentit
palier mais en tout cas la décision est
prise on coeur
la jci est content ému
franchement je suis ému parce que
l'amour triomphe toujours tellement
donné à red bull sa triumph entre vous
et j'ai offert une bague ya deux ans aux
personnages qui sont que tu es toujours
pas remariée non mais c'est beau voilà à
réussir et que c'est moi je suis content
pour eux elle a déposé sa liste de
mariage peut déjà acheter des couteaux
s'aiguisent au grain
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et nabila beaucoup d'autodérision le
prendra bien vous inquiétez pas ne vous
coûtera pas un couteau dans le dos